[Applaudissements]
chacun avait son côté sud islam qu'un
seul naturel habituel contre
l'homophobie
parce que
je prends mon envol décolle et vole
survola cette nature qui devient folle
dans cette dégradation tout le monde
joue à vol et dans ce monde consécutive
l'homme
nomade je me balade sur terre en mer
comme dans les airs d'un fureteur je
cherche de sabots centenaire perdu dans
cette nature nourricière
ils sont rares et précieux car l'humain
que très peu je regarde d'en haut depuis
le nuage est triste paysage envahi par
des pirates qui font des ravages
même s'il a comme avec nos smartphones
et vous bien plus qu'un banal font des
constats téléphone à le toit qui a les
mains liées à ton phone tabs le moteur
de recherche dioxyde de carbone et
humains tenant compte des dangers sur la
couche d'ozone dans l'affairé n'est pas
habituel elle est bien réelle
pourquoi être addict aux jeux vidéo
alors que durant l air frais plus comme
une tata et fait du bien et nous
commencer vous
[Musique]
effet résister à toute heure
je pouvais
ces matches et tout cela me révolte
vous le but de nous d'une manière
injurieuse et abusif
tous avouent se faire remarquer parfois
parfois je me demande si vous êtes
conscient de ce que vous dites
et tout cela me révolte et mai est le
plus beau des sentiments qu'on soit gay
hétéro ou lesbienne peu importe les
conséquences
moi je dis à l'homophobie stop à
l'homophobie
[Musique]
un petit tournoi antilles c'est comme
jamais public applaudit et bien sûr
[Applaudissements]